i have confidence that the uk will do
everything within its possibility to
allow
for full participation of all countries
to be able to come
that is not an easy task under current
conditions
so i am guided by uh the assessment of
the car
president but if it turns out
that some people aren't able to come
because of the covid crisis
should it be postponed i don't think the
cop can actually go forward without
governmental representation full
governmental representation
and i am certain that the uk government
will ensure
that there is representation of 195
countries
what may be much more challenging is to
ensure
the representation of the private sector
of civil society of the scientists
of all of the different constituencies
that
surround the negotiations that may be
a bit trickier but full
government representation of 195 nations
needs to be there and i am certain that
the uk is putting that in place
and as hosts of cop 26 is the uk
doing enough to cut its emissions well
you see anna it's very important to
differentiate two roles that the uk is
playing
at the same time first of all alex
sharma is the incoming
cop president and as such he cannot
take a uk position he needs
actually to detach himself if you will
from the uk position
and from what the uk does to be able to
be
the correct and im impersonal
and neutral cop president that he needs
to be he is doing a brilliant job of
that
he is doing it under very trying
circumstances very difficult to travel
right now
and build up the trust in relationships
that he needs to build up
but he is doing a brilliant job of that
on the side of that
is the uk government different than the
role
of the cop presidency and the uk
government
is currently in process of struggling
frankly to align
all of the policies that are in the
energy sector in the transport sector in
all of the sectors
that they need now let's remember that
the uk was the first country to commit
to net zero in national law
but the implementation across all
agencies is
a work in progress and a huge job so
what do you think
needs to change about the uk's policies
the uk needs actually um to take a look
at what the united states is doing we
had four years of darkness
around climate change in the united
states and what the united states has
done now
is not just dovetail itself into
where the world is on climate change but
actually take a step forward
and give a very very clear monday to
all agencies to all departments that
they are to do their domestic job but
they need to do it through the lens of
climate change
so the united states has actually come
from behind
to the front it is today the only
country
that is having an all of government
approach to climate change
that is something that the uk but also
every other country
can and should emulate and the u.s
climate envoy john kerry
is visiting china what does he need to
get out of that visit
he is visiting china and korea
in in preparation for the biden climate
summit that will occur april 22 and 23
and um i am suspecting that
he is re-engaging with the chinese
leaders who he knows very well from his
previous position
as well as with korea to ensure that
they will come
to the biden summit with a very
clear upgrade let's say of their current
ambition on climate change we've talked
about governments but who should take
responsibility
for cutting emissions around the world
is it governments or is it corporations
is it individuals who should be
shouldering the burden
well actually all of the above ana this
is
too important and too large
to actually be exported to any one
sector
either to national governments or
sub-national city regional governments
or private sector or citizens
or financial sector the fact is that
because we have delayed
so long on beginning the firm
descent of emissions now it is
an all hands-on deck effort everyone
needs to collaborate and the good thing
about that
is that as each sector gets engaged
there is a mutually reinforcing effect
that happens so that we can progress not
gradually not
in a linear fashion but exponentially
which is what we have to do
you say that everyone has a
responsibility but individuals
in the uk for example might say look at
china
it's responsible for a quarter of all
emissions any
individual decision i make here is going
to make no difference so why should i
well it is true that china currently has
uh has one quarter of emissions but
let's remember the historical
responsibility that the uk
has having been the birthplace of the
industrial revolution
which is exactly what got us into this
situation to begin with
that is why it is so important that the
uk has actually
engaged already years ago in phasing out
of coal
and moving toward renewable energies
that's why it's so important
that the uk has assumed a net zero
target
in its national law because the uk
understands
that they need to change the course now
individuals
are a very important part of that
because
we collectively as individuals but
collectively
we represent demand in the economy and
so when we
as individuals demand clean
efficient non-polluting transport
then corporations take note and provide
that
when we as individuals demand
non-emitting food that is better for our
bodies
and better for planetary health
corporations take note
and develop more options
that are with plant-based protein
when we as individuals demand cities
that are actually organized for
pedestrians
for humans and not necessarily for cars
bridges and roads
then urban planners take note and make
the necessary changes
and the same thing occurs with
insulation
insulation and if energy efficiency in
the uk
is a huge huge job creating opportunity
that allows us as dwellers in homes
offices buildings in uh in the uk
to have lower electric bills and
do something that is good by the planet
and what about poorer nations who are
struggling with debt many of them and
who are most likely to be affected by
climate change
there were commitments in the paris
agreement for richer nations to to help
them out
those commitments aren't being fulfilled
properly are they so what needs to
happen
well first we have to be able to help
developing nations to
decouple their greenhouse gas emissions
from their gdp
growth we actually already have 32
countries that have done that
including the uk but that is
that decoupling that
distancing gdp growth from
geode from carbon emissions is a process
that needs to occur not only in
industrialized countries but also in
developing countries
and we already have several developing
countries that are
on that path including mexico including
jamaica including el salvador
they are countries that have are
continuing
to grow economically because they need
to bring their people out of poverty
but they're not doing so following the
path of the global north
based on the burning of fossil fuels
they have moved over
that is the kind of support both
technical and financial
that the global north needs to give the
global south
so that the global south can continue
the development
that they need but do so in a clean
fashion
and is there still time to solve the
climate crisis and if so how long have
we got
well first anna let's be
very humble to accept that we will never
solve climate change
because the damage that has been done
the concentrations that are up there
will already have hundreds of years
of impact so we cannot turn the clock
back on climate change what we can do is
we can shave off the worst impacts of
climate change
and for that we need to half
our emissions 50 cut of global emissions
by 2030. it may sound like a huge
um effort but it is completely doable
especially
if governments do it corporations
individuals
every single sector does it then it is
actually possible
that is what science has told us science
has been warning us for
decades about this but we are really now
standing
at the edge of a precipice by 2030
we will have collectively decided
whether we're able to move on
to a future that is actually much
healthier
more stable more just and of more growth
and prosperity
and better livelihoods than those that
we have now
of course if we don't cut our emissions
in half
we're facing a future of constant
destruction and untold human misery
that's not the future we want and that
is not the future we're condemned to